bonjour à tous
chers amis messieurs les sénateur
monsieur notre invité Monsieur Philippe
bouclier et ce qui vous accompagne
nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir ici au Sénat j'espère que
vous avez pas eu trop de difficultés
pour arriver on n'a pas pu enlever les
poubelles vous avez pu remarquer pour le
moment peut-être que le roi Charles
quand il arrivera lundi les choses
seront
j'en doute un peu mais
bien écoutez voilà j'ai l'honneur de
représenter le président de vidas qui
malheureusement est absent aujourd'hui
et n'a pas pu être ici pour votre
audition
au côté de notre rapporteur voilà je
vais donc vous dire quelques mots de
d'introduction
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
mission d'information
sur le développement d'une filière de
biocarburant les carburants synthétiques
également durables hydrogène vert par
l'audition donc de vous monsieur le
Président boucli président de France
hydrogène
monsieur bouclier est accompagné de
Madame Christelle Verquin délégué
général de France hydrogène de monsieur
Simon pujeau responsable des relations
institutionnelles
je rappelle que cette réunion est captée
et diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
ensuite être consultée en vidéo bien sûr
à la demande de celui qui le désire
monsieur le Président bouclier au cours
de votre carrière vous avez occupé de
nombreuses fonctions dans la filière gaz
vous avez en particulier été directeur
de GRTgaz et c'est sur votre mandat que
l'entreprise a pris le virage des gaz
renouvelables et en particulier de
l'hydrogène je rappelle que nous avons
fait ici l'année dernière un rapport sur
la méthanisation et le développement de
la méthanisation je sais si nous avions
anticipé des choses avant les conflits
donc c'était même en 2021 avant même
qu'il y ait les conflits en Europe
centrale
depuis décembre 2017 vous êtes le
président de France hydrogène ex
association française pour l'hydrogène
et l'épile à combustibles France
hydrogène regroupe à ce jour plus de 450
membres et fédère l'ensemble des acteurs
de la filière française de l'hydrogène
monsieur bouclier notre mission
d'information comprend des membres issus
de différentes commissions qui
représentent l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat avec mes collègues
nous sommes convaincus de l'enjeu que
représente le développement des filables
de biocarburant de carburant synthétique
durable et d'hydrogène vert tant pour la
capacité de la France et de l'Union
européenne à atteint l'objectif de
neutralité climatique à l'horizon 2050
que pour notre souveraineté et la
compétitivité de notre économie
la notion d'iden vert fait l'objet de
nombreuses discussions au niveau de
l'Union européenne je pense que vous
l'évoquerez et vous pourrez nous
préciser les différentes nuances
d'hydrogène nous serons également
heureux d'entendre votre vision du rôle
de l'hydrogène dans la décarbonation des
transports
sera-t-il réservé à la mobilité lourde
ou peut-il jouer un rôle beaucoup plus
large
notre rapporteur monsieur Vincent capot
canular
vous a adressé un questionnaire assez
réduit de 21 questions voilà il est
évident que si vous ne pouvez pas si
nous n'avons pas le temps de répondre à
toutes ces questions vous pourrez
toujours de toute façon les compléter
par des écrits que vous pourrez envoyer
ici à nos services voilà c'est que c'est
un peu vous servir de guide mais
sentez-vous libre dans vos propos
introdifs bien évidemment je passerai
ensuite la parole à notre rapporteur
puis à l'ensemble de mes collègues ici
présent afin qu'il puisse vous relancer
et vous poser un certain nombre de
bonnes questions vous pourrez nous
transmettre également
ultérieurement des réponses écrites
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure voilà
je vous souhaite donc monsieur bouquet
la parole vous prenez le temps qu'il
vous faut nous sommes là pour faire en
sorte que la filière hydrogène soit bien
comprise ici au Sénat et que nous
puissions monsieur le rapport EUR avoir
les bonnes réponses aux questions que
nous nous posons vous avez la parole
merci Monsieur
occuper merci Monsieur de nous recevoir
pour faire un peu le point sur la
filière hydrogène en matière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique et
plus généralement décarbonation de la de
la mobilité alors je rappellerai pas que
la stratégie française de l'hydrogène
c'est trois axes trois piliers
fondamentaux des carbonés à
l'industriels des carboner la mobilité
lourde ou intensive et maintenir à haut
niveau d'excellence et notamment par un
programme prioritaire de recherche alors
ce que nous sommes efforcé de faire en
2022 c'est de collecter l'ensemble des
projets qui sont dans les cartons des
porteurs de projets en France c'est plus
de 250 projets que nous avons réuni
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
simplement au niveau de l'industrie ça
dépasse largement ce que nous avions
anticipé et c'est à dire 815000 tonnes
au-delà des 600 000 que nous avions
anticipé et sur ces 815000 tonnes c'est
420 425000 tonnes de molécules de
synthèse
c'est par exemple du imethanol pour
205000 tonnes des électrocarburants pour
165000 tonnes et d'autres carburants
comme du méthane de synthèse pour 55000
tonnes j'y reviendrai après sur certains
projets emblématiques qui sont déjà
qui sont déjà bien avancés aucune
décision finale d'investissement des
prises mais qui sont déjà bien avancés
et si ces 425000 tonnes on ajoute 260
000 tonnes de mobilité à hydrogène
toujours collectés par cette collecte
réalisée en 2022 on voit que la mobilité
sur le million de tonnes de projets la
mobilité et largement majoritaire
alors justement je vais justement
rentrer plus en détail sur la mobilité
et en particulier signaler également que
au-delà de cette
étude cette collecte des projets nous
avons également réalisé avec la PFA avec
la plateforme automobile en 2022
également et avec l'aide de l'IRT
systémique une étude d'optimisation
d'une structure de recharge pour
Véhicule
véhicule utilitaire léger toujours en
ligne avec la stratégie nationale donc
véhicule utilitaire léger et poids
lourds et on arrive ainsi alors je
pourrais revenir sur les chiffres aussi
vous le souhaitez mais on arrive ainsi à
l'horizon
2030 à 920 stations à la fois pour
alimenter recharger des véhicules
utilitaires légers et pour recharger des
poids lourds alors maintenant je vais
rentrer plus en détail dans les
différentes catégories de mobilité pour
les véhicules utilitaires légers
c'est un parc de près de 7 millions de
véhicules utilitaires légers qui est qui
tourne actuellement en France plus
exactement c'est 6,6 millions et dans ce
parc on constate que plus de 25% font
plus de 250 km par jour
et donc
les véhicules utilitaires à batterie
alors on nous dit qu'ils certains ont
une autonomie qui va jusqu'à 250 km mais
enfin c'est un peu la limite et pour le
recharger il faut enfin sauf si vous
avez une charge ultra rapide il faut
plusieurs heures en revanche pour le
véhicule utilitaire à hydrogène vous
avez largement plus de 400 km
d'autonomie et vous faites le plein
entre 5 et 10 minutes donc là nous
sommes fondés et c'est ce qui a servi
également de d'hypothèses pour l'étude
d'infrastructure dont je parlais sont
fondés sur le les hypothèses du Wapo ou
à Pau c'est donc une étude prospective
je vous fais grâce du du mot anglais des
mots anglais passer une étude
prospective menée avec et pour la
filière française de l'automobile
qui estime qu'à l'horizon 2030 on
devrait avoir 240 000 véhicules
utilitaires légers à hydrogène donc 240
000 sur un parc je rappelle 6006
et 2040 ils ont des projections jusqu'à
2040 c'est
760 000 véhicules c'est-à-dire on est un
peu plus de on est à peu près à 10% du
parc
tout ça pour replacer donc le véhicule
utilitaire léger à hydrogène dans
l'ensemble du panorama des véhicules de
la mobilité
utile je dirais
des véhicules utilitaires légers
français
j'ajouterai à cela que nous avons quand
même la chance en France d'avoir deux
champions de la construction des
véhicules utilitaires légers à la fois
steliantis avec sa gamme Jumpy expert
Vivaro
véhicules qui va construire en France à
Hordain dans le Nord et également à évia
donc cette filiale entre Renault et plug
power qui va faire des masters enfin une
déclineuses déclinaison sous trois sous
trois formes je dirais
pour justement
alimenter ce marché des véhicules
utilitaires légers et enfin
dans le cadre de du projet important
enfin vous savez que l'hydrogène a été
installé je dirais a été considéré comme
un projet important d'intérêt européen
commun et donc il y a un certain nombre
de vagues ça permet de débloquer les
aides d'État pour les champions que les
États veulent soutenir la première vague
qui est sur les briques technologiques
électrolyseur réservoir puis la
combustible
a donné largement un avantage de la
France puisque sur les 41 projets
retenus de cette première vague 10 sont
français c'est des fabricants
d'électrolyseurs les 4 fabricants
d'électrolyseurs c'est les fabricants de
piles de fabricants de piles c'est un
bio et
Lyon des fabricants de réservoir
plastique omium Forestia et puis
également Arkema qui travaille sur la
les membranes et alvia que j'ai déjà
cité
donc voilà ce que je vais dire sur les
véhicules utilitaires légers sur les
camions nous avons produit en France
hydrogène à produit en février 2022 un
livre blanc sur les sur les camions
là dans l'étude dont je parlais donc
toujours le Wapo nous avons considéré
8500 camions à l'horizon 2030
51 000 à l'horizon 2035 80 90
000 à l'horizon 2040
8500 c'est 1,4% du parc et 2040 c'est
15% du parc
alors il est clair que si le camion fait
de de faible distance c'est-à-dire moins
de 50000 km par an la batterie fera le
job il n'y a pas de il y a pas de débat
là-dessus en revanche dès que vous allez
avoir plus de 80
000 à 100000 km par an pour les la gamme
ceston 32 tonnes et plus de 140 000 km
par an pour la gamme 32 44 tonnes
l'hydrogène s'impose naturellement
simplement quelques chiffres si pour un
44 tonnes si vous voulez lui donner 500
km d'autonomie
il vous faut une batterie de enfin
l'ensemble batterie c'est 3 tonnes 6 si
vous le rechargez avec une avec une
prise de 50 kW qui est déjà pas petit
mais il faut 13 100 kW 7 heures et 350
km deux heures si vous passez à
l'hydrogène c'est pas trois tonnes 6
mais c'est une tonne 8 donc la moitié
donc vous gagnez une tonne 8 de charge
utile et vous gagnez et vous perdez pas
beaucoup par rapport au diesel puisque
le diesel fait à peu près une tonne donc
vous perdez 800 800 kg
et
vous avez donc cette autonomie ça c'est
l'hypothèse et vous recharger en 15 à 20
minutes donc d'un côté minimum deux
heures avec une prise de 350 kW ce qui
est pas donné enfin ce qui n'existe pas
pas encore beaucoup actuellement et de
l'autre côté 15 à 20 minutes donc là je
dirais le maître mot dans ces questions
là c'est ne pas être surtout ne pas être
dogmatique et ça dépend fondamentalement
des cas d'usage et surtout ne pas
s'arrêter à strictement au rendement
mais regardez les questions d'autonomie
regardez les questions de disponibilité
si vous si je sais pas si les pompiers
ou la police adoptent un master alors
qu'il soit sûr de faire le faire le
trajet et donc ça a quand même plus
simple d'être rechargé à l'hydrogène
plutôt que qu'elle a la batterie cette
disponibilité permanente et puis
s'interroger aussi
sur les matériaux critiques il y aura
quand même beaucoup plus de matériaux
critiques dans des camions à batterie
plutôt comme un camion hydrogène donc
cas d'usage et ne pas s'arrêter au
rendement seul
c'est si vrai que il y a un certain
nombre d'utilisateurs qui souhaitent
passer rapidement à
disons à l'hydrogène alors les
constructeurs de camions se bousculent
pas pour faire leur camion hydrogène je
dois encore venir et en revanche vous
avez tout le rétrofit et il y a une
coalition rétrophique qui s'est
constituée qui est constitué à la fois
de
d'énergéticiens d'équipementiers
Faurecia Plastic Omnium de
de chargeurs de transporteurs et de
clients clients qui veulent notamment
assurer un transport propre à leur
marchandises donc et vous avez des un
certain nombre de sociétés des startups
qui se montent actuellement on va les
appeler
d'un mot nouveau rétrofiteur enfin des
spécialisés dans le rétrofit donc il
vous démontent l'ensemble de la partie
gasoil ou essence et ils vous mettent à
la place pile à combustible réservoir
faut encore sûrement une petite batterie
mais en tout cas
il passe à l'hydrogène on a quelques
quelques membres de l'association qui
font ce travail
voilà ce que je voulais dire rapidement
sur les camions sur le
sur le transport maritime là il faut
saluer le travail du cluster maritime
français et puis de de également du CSF
mère
ou je note notamment la volonté pour le
comité stratégique de filière de
d'augmenter le soutage en France qui
actuellement je crois qu'il y a un
bateau sur enfin ils ont un cinquième du
soutage se fait en France et le souhait
d'augmenter ce soudage la question qui
se pose et il y a pas encore de réponse
définitive sur ce point c'est quel
combustible le méthanol en est un parmi
d'autres mais il y a eu un moment un
engouement si j'ose dire pour l'ammoniac
on aperçu un peu la toxicité on amuse
apprécier la toxicité de l'ammoniac et
ça risque enfin ça perd un peu de de
d'intérêt pour l'instant
quant à l'hydrogène liquide ça prend
beaucoup de place ça prend beaucoup plus
de place que le que les carburants
actuels
quant au mode de propulsion lui-même
est-ce que c'est une pile à combustible
est-ce que c'est un moteur à combustion
alimentée par ces carburants de synthèse
c'est encore la réflexion ce qui semble
se dégager quand même c'est que pour les
petites puissances c'est-à-dire jusqu'à
2 mégawatts ou tu as dit un bateau de
pêche bateau de service pour le l'éolien
offshore le
la pile à combustible devrait convenir
pour les plus grosses puissances ça a
probablement un moteur à combustion
interne
et pour l'instant ça semble le méthanol
semble tenir la corde je me réfère en
disant ça aux commandes que merk se
viennent
passergm lui embête lui emboîte le pas
donc
et donc je rappelle donc ces chiffres
que j'ai cité en début de ma
présentation dans cette collecte de
projets 2030 c'est 25000 tonnes qui
d'hydrogène qui devrait aller à la
production méthanol qui devrait donc
aboutir contenu des ratios à peu près un
million de tonnes de méthanol à cet
horizon
on a quelques sociétés qui se
positionnent pour faire ce méthanol la
société h2v par exemple la société Élise
engie également
s'agissant de l'aérien là aussi les
choses
il y a un spécialiste parmi vous donc je
vais pas m'aventurer trop trop loin mais
en tout cas ce qui semble se décider
c'est que pour les alors le les petits
avions et très courts distances la
batterie il y aura des avions à batterie
par contre pour les le moyen courrier
l'hydrogène semble convenir le long
courrier serait plutôt des carburants de
synthèse qu'on appelle les Suisses
ténéboles aviation fiouls les safs ou
les cadres français les carburants
déviation durable
donc là également dans cette étude nous
avions collecté 165
000 tonnes
et
donc là pour simplement pour dire que
les choses se mettent en place alors en
conclusant je vois que le temps mais
méconté en conclusion je voudrais dire
que un il faudrait
faut bien tenir compte des synergies
c'est à dire que le développement de
carburant de synthèse va faire un appel
par exemple de un certain nombre
d'équipements et notamment
d'électrolyseur et par conséquent c'est
ça va disons contribuer à la
massification et par conséquent réduire
les coûts
donc faudra tenir compte de ces enfin
bien tenir compte de cette synergie
entre mobilité et et industrie les
choses ne sont pas séparées
deuxième point très général il faut
accélérer sur l'énergie ça ça paraît
évident on n'aura jamais trop d'énergie
renouvelables ou bas carbone et là ça va
amène sur le je dirais le combat qu'on
parce que c'est un combat comme un
actuellement à Bruxelles pour faire
reconnaître l'hydrogène bas carbone dans
l'atteinte des cibles de des carbonation
que ce soit du transport ou de ou de
l'industrie bon là on se heurte vraiment
un mur idéologique qui semble enfin des
progrès ont été faits mais c'est pas
encore gagné
dans le même ordre d'idées qui dit
carburant de synthèse il faut de
l'hydrogène propre renouvelable ou bas
carbone mais il faut aussi de du gaz
carbonique et le enfin il faut du
carbone et ce carbone il faut qu'il soit
biogénique sinon on n'a pas gagné
grand chose sauf pour ce que nous
appelons le carbone inévitable
c'est notamment le carbone
issu de des cimenterie ou de la
fabrication de la chaux et je rappelle
quand même que sur les 56 les plus
émetteurs de de gaz à effet de serre en
France 24 sont soit décimantrices soit
des fours à chaud donc il y a un sujet
là alors des projets notamment la
société le cimentier Vicat avec avec à
INAMI x la filiale hydrogène de EDF
avait un gros projet de production je
dis avait parce que dans un gros projet
de production de méthanol à partir de
gaz carbonique capté sur la cheminée de
la cimenterie
ceci étant les les actes l'acte délégué
publié le 13 février
bloque je dirais à 2040 l'utilisation de
ce gaz
carbonique industriel
et donc
ce qui a conduit Vicat et à une amie ça
redimensionné le projet à la baisse de
façon à ne prendre en compte que le gaz
carbonique biogénique
issue de
[Musique]
disons de la biomasse qui sert de
combustible à la cimenterie
donc au lieu de faire 200000 tonnes
comme c'était prévu initialement avec
330 MW de d'électrolyse il ne prévoit
plus que d'en faire 120 000 tonnes donc
80000 tonnes de moins avec 200 MW
d'électrolyse
donc là je dirais et ça m'amène
également un troisième une troisième
remarque c'est que faudra bien prendre
en compte bien prendre garde que les
règles sont les mêmes pour tous et au
niveau mondial pour dire en bon français
faire level playing field enfin terrain
de jeu égal pour tous
et là également si vous voyez le les
règles adoptées pour le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone frontières ça
touche un certain nombre de produits
dans l'hydrogène mais pas c'est dérivés
et donc pas le méthanol ou les
carburants de synthèse qui pourraient
être fait avec avec l'hydrogène
sur le plan français et je terminerai
par cela vous savez que donc la révision
de la stratégie est en cours
là je j'insiste sur le fait qu'il faut
absolument qu'on marche sur deux jambes
et c'est à dire que il faudrait pas
privilégier la décarbonation au
détriment de la mobilité ou de la reine
industrialisation c'est à dire que il
faudrait pas qu'on se contente entre
guillemets de décarboner un certain
nombre de sites industriels ou de
certains bassins et de laisser de côté
tout ce qui concerne la mobilité
mobilité sur les grands axes et dans le
cas de ce que j'ai dit c'est à dire
mobilité lourde ou intensive parce que
parce qu'on a ces champions qui sont
capables de faire des véhicules
utilitaires légers parce que on a ce
mouvement de qui veut des poids lourds
propres parce que il y a tout un tissu
industriel de fabrication de réservoirs
fabrication depuis la combustible
fabrication d'électrolyseur qui est
motivé et que qui a déjà été financé
dans le cadre dans le cadre de l'ipcei
de ce projet important d'intérêt
européen commun donc bien ces deux
jambes c'est des carbonation et
réindustrialisation
voilà je sais pas si j'ai dépassé je
suis un peu dépassé mon temps
c'est passionnant parce que j'ai
l'impression que vous avez rien dit
tellement il y a de choses à dire en
tout cas le but que nous attendons quand
je vois le questionnaire qui a été
évoqué juste une première approche vous
n'avez pas parler du tout des coûts vous
avez pas les différentes énergies est-ce
que vous avez pu est-ce que vous avez un
élément qui nous permettrait de comparer
tous les coûts de énergie par énergie
voire même des coûts comparé par rapport
aux énergies fossiles aujourd'hui
ça dépend de quel secteur il s'agit ça
dépend à quoi ça s'applique c'est-à-dire
que la fabrication de l'hydrogène et des
coûts associés il faut prendre en compte
toute la logistique de transport et de
distribution et donc on n'aura pas un
même coup à la pompe évidemment si
ça c'est juste pour l'hydrogène direct
dans la mobilité après l'écoute de
production et transformation associée
aux molécules de synthèse sont enfin il
existe je crois pour le Ikea Rosen des
éléments je crois que c'est quand même
significativement plus onéreux
évidemment mais on n'a pas de coût
à donner là depuis ton blanc enfin ça
s'applique pas comme ça aussi simplement
ce que j'entends c'est 4 à 5 fois plus
cher mais je ne fais que répéter ce que
j'entends être confirmé monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président bouclier merci d'avoir de
votre exposé vous avez plaidé tous les
atouts de la filière hydrogène et pour
avoir regardé notamment votre site je
veux d'abord vous remercier parce qu'il
y a un certain nombre d'éléments de
vulgarisation et au-delà qui font que
vous arrivez à rendre des éléments
techniques compliqués à peu près
intelligible donc c'est déjà un point
majeur parce qu'on est dans un domaine
évidemment de haute technologie
je voudrais quand même vous interroger
au-delà de
tout ce que vous avez dit de positif sur
la filière et c'est votre rôle sur un
peu sur les limites parce que il n'y a
pas que l'hydrogène notre mission
d'information le président l'a rappelé
et porte sur notre vecteurs et d'autres
d'autres carburants également qui sont
aussi des carburants verts mais d'abord
comment rendre cet hydrogène
véritablement vert bon vous avez parlé
notamment de l'électrolyse et un certain
nombre d'éléments techniques et c'est un
élément majeur que que de bien situer
les choses techniquement où est-ce qu'on
en est est-ce que
les règles du jeu sont sont claires
donc sur les sources sur le procédé vous
avez abordé un certain nombre de couples
potentiels avec tout ce qui concerne la
mobilité j'ai noté les véhicules
utilitaires léger les les camions bon le
maritime l'aérien mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas quand même un
certain nombre de points qui feraient
que l'hydrogène serait moins à
développer que d'autres que d'autres
vecteurs
par exemple vous avez abordé la question
des poids lourds en donnant des chiffres
qui sont d'aller vers 15% du parc pour
2040 nous avons auditionné
un certain nombre de d'intervenants pas
continuer on va continuer pendant un pas
fini mais on a parfois entendu que en
matière de mobilité et de poids lourds
la filière prenait d'autres options vous
même vous avez dit je crois que tout à
l'heure les constructions de Bolos ne se
bousculent pas donc voilà quelles sont
les limites pour vous du développement
de la filière quels sont les points
qu'il faut privilégier est-ce que vous
pouvez un peu hiérarchiser tout ça
notamment on va vers la révision de la
stratégie nationale
est-ce que il y a pas un recentrage vers
plutôt l'industrie vous avez beaucoup
parlé de mobilité mais ce que nous avons
entendu dans certains interlocuteurs S
qui sont venus dans cette mission c'est
quand même plutôt que
compte tenu
d'un certain nombre d'éléments
techniques parfois d'ailleurs aussi
question sur les enjeux de sécurité pour
la mobilité
il y a un rapport qui a été publié il y
a quelques mois de ça déjà par la
situation générale du développement
durable et
le commissariat général au développement
durable également sur ce sujet là mais
est-ce que sur la partie
mobilité
légère ou poids lourds la question de la
sécurité ne peut pas être pas être
limite
la stratégie de l'État vous l'avez
abordé c'est souvent les appels à projet
est-ce que ça vous paraît une bonne
manière de procéder au début peut-être
pour faire émerger un certain nombre
d'acteurs pour regarder faire vivre les
solutions technologiques mais à quel
moment est-ce qu'on va resserrer un peu
la focale et avoir une stratégie
peut-être plus affirmée avec des choix à
l'intérieur puis enfin je laisserai la
parole à mes collègues mais on entend
parler de
déploiement de production d'hydrogène en
tâche de léopard vous avez quelque part
allusion en disant qu'on avait souvent
une logique qui concernait la
production auprès des sites industriels
et donc en fonction des besoins des
territoires mais on nous vend un peu
cette idée de tâches de léopard nous
disons finalement on va peut-être
ou peut-être pas mettre en réseau un
jour ces sites de production est-ce que
c'est la bonne la bonne technique de
votre point de vue on a encore entendu
ça assez récemment
je vais essayer
je vais répondre à toutes ces questions
je sais pas j'ai deux heures c'est bien
ça
non parce que j'ai évoqué ou décrit
plutôt que
véhicule tititaire léger
[Musique]
poids lourd maritime et aérien me semble
être les enfin sont les options sans
regret que sur lequel
l'hydrogène doit être employée donc on
n'est pas pour la voiture de monsieur
madame tout le monde à l'hydrogène et
donc ça c'est pas du tout le le sujet et
j'ai même dit que pour le poids lourd ça
dépend du cas d'usage donc si vous
voulez je crois qu'il faut se garder de
ceux qui arrivent en disant on a la
solution pour tout et ça va répondre à
tous vos besoins c'est ce que j'ai dit
et je le répète se garder de toute
position dogmatique et bien regardée le
le cas du d'usage
les cas d'usage en termes de
disponibilité en termes de temps de
recharge si
l'artisan qui aura demain à rentrer dans
une zone faible mission si il attend
toute la nuit de recharger il prend une
voiture à batterie et il sera très
content il y a pas de souci mais je vous
ai donné les chiffres pour un
poids lourd de 44 tonnes à qui voulait
faire 500 km ça va prendre un peu de
temps donc et tant mieux si vous êtes le
premier sur la borne si vous êtes le
deuxième ça va déjà vous avez
avoir du temps pour manger votre
sandwich les
[Musique]
les limites de développement de la
filière
c'est pas des limites mais
[Musique]
je répète il faut accélérer sur le
développement des énergies des carbonées
c'est-à-dire à la fois l'électricité
renouvelable ou bas carbone donc c'est
les travaux que vous avez menés loin
d'accélération sur les renouvelables loi
d'accélération sur le nucléaire et donc
ça c'est
de façon enfin si on parle des énergies
elles-mêmes biomasse et puis électricité
s'agissant de la révision
[Musique]
j'apprécie votre question sur la
révision de la stratégie nationale
c'est une crainte que nous avons c'est
ce que j'ai dit en conclusion une
crainte que nous avons que on ne
se contente entre guillemets je remets
les guillemets de décarboner un certain
nombre de sites voire de bassins au
détriment de l'ensemble du territoire
alors je sais bien que les bassins
concentre une bonne partie de la
production d'hydrogène et du besoin
d'hydrogène mais il y a quand même ce
cette mobilité dont j'ai parlé mobilité
qui concerne alors je parlais des poids
lourds le parc français mais il y a il
faut voir aussi que les autres les
Allemands les Néerlandais vont aussi se
mettre au camion à hydrogène et ils
auront besoin d'aller chercher des
légumes et des fruits en Espagne il
faudra bien qui qui recharge donc il y a
aussi il y a dans nos dans les modèles
dans les modèles et dans les hypothèses
adoptées par le parc systémique la l'IRT
qui nous a fait l'étude il y a la prise
en compte effectivement d'un transit de
camions étrangers sur le territoire
français
moi ce que je crois c'est que si on
[Musique]
se contente encore une fois entre
guillemets de
décarboner les grands sites on va se
retrouver dans deux ou trois ans avec
une invasion de véhicules qui viendront
de Chine d'Allemagne ou d'ailleurs et on
se réveillera alors qu'on a à la fois
ces champions je suis désolé mais on a
si vous cherchez un véhicule utilitaire
léger actuellement à l'hydrogène vous
n'aurez que cet élianisme et Renault et
on a ses fabricants de composants on a
plastic Omnium
Faurecia on a
Symbio on a et Lyon qui sont tous prêts
à produire massivement leurs produits
alors s'agissant de est-ce que le modèle
des le soutien pour l'instant c'est fait
effectivement essentiellement avec les
appels à projets de l'ADEME
c'est
46 projets qui ont été soutenus pour un
montant total de 320 millions sur un
investi en total de 1 milliard 2
effectivement les les projets sont
plutôt de petites étaient plutôt de
petite taille c'est bien été perçue et
reçu par l'ADEME qui dans son nouvel
appel à projet va relever le seuil je
bus c'est 20 ou 30 mW c'est 20 mg
dans les appels à projets écosystème
territoriaux de l'ADEME dans le cahier
des charges c'est deux mégawatts et sur
le mécanisme de soutien la production
mais qui est également une limite au
sens où on attend toujours la piste en
œuvre on est sur un cahier des charges
avec plutôt 30 mW d'électrolyse
alors quant au développement en tâche de
léopard j'aime bien l'image
c'est effectivement mais comment se
développer le gaz naturel en France
chaque ville avait son usine à gaz son
réseau puis à un moment on a
interconnecté ces différents réseaux
j'imagine que pour le pour l'hydrogène
ça va se passer de la même façon et dès
que vous avez
là aussi il faut pas être dogmatique il
y a déjà regardé ce que fait
jertégase que ce soit à dans le Sud avec
un framed ou dans la région dans le Nord
entre quasiment entre Valenciennes et
Dunkerque ils font des appels à
manifestation d'intérêt
les disons les clients potentiels
répondent plutôt positivement et bon
ensuite là ils vont entamer une phase un
peu plus
engageante où il va falloir que les
clients potentiels contribuent à une
étude
pour voir une étude de faisabilité pour
voir dans quelle mesure un réseau
s'installe mais dès que vous allez avoir
des quantités encore plus importantes là
ça va par exemple ça se passe bien
puisque vous avez un gros pôle de
consommation d'hydrogène donc c'est la
région de fosse Marseille donc un groupe
de consommation avec raffinerie
chirurgie chimie et vous avez un
stockage à proximité à Manosque une
centaine de kilomètres donc ça se place
bien mais dès que vous allez avoir des
Dunkerque Dunkerque si un industriel qui
veut de l'hydrogène 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 il va falloir assurer cette
continuité de fourniture et donc à être
liée à des stockages souterrains et donc
vous allez très vite avoir besoin de
d'une infrastructure donc alors
l'alternative c'est effectivement
d'amener l'électricité par des câbles
c'est le dialogue ou le débat ça dépend
à quel niveau de l'intensité on se parle
entre donc amener l'énergie sous forme
d'électricité ou l'amener sous forme de
gaz
demander à RTE les la file d'attente et
le temps pour raccorder pour amener
l'énergie à telle site là pour l'instant
il regarde par exemple sur fosse amené
un gigawatt le besoin de la zone c'est 5
gigawatts donc il peut être
éventuellement intéressant et évidemment
RTE et grtgas si emploi de regarder s'il
est pas plus intéressant de faire
l'hydrogène à côté d'une centrale
nucléaire par exemple au hasard enfin
d'un côté d'un site de production
d'électricité et d'amener l'hydrogène
gazeux sur sur fosse plutôt que d'amener
un câble qui amène l'électricité et qui
transporte les pertes de l'électrolyseur
pour faire l'hydrogène à fosse donc
c'est ce débat mais là aussi il faut pas
être dogmatique tout va être possible ça
dépend au cas par cas de regarder les
situations
est-ce que chers collègues vous avez des
questions à poser je pense le sénateur
de la Marne
heureusement touché par le groupe de
Vitry-le-François
les raisonnements que j'ai entendu
là-bas c'est la même approche mais j'ai
l'impression que ça avance pas vite
on est toujours impatient vous nous en
excusez mais on a l'impression que ça
avance pas vite non c'est une idée au
moins aussi impression si ce n'est plus
que que vous
qu'est-ce qu'on constate dans cette
étude dans cette collecte de l'an
dernier on a 70% des projets qui donc
250 projets collectés 250 projets
collectés plutôt des petits projets donc
70% sont à moins de 2 mégawatt et 24
projets concentre 80% des
usages donc besoin de massifier et mais
en revanche on voit qu'il y a très peu
de décisions finales d'investissement je
viens à votre impatience pourquoi il y a
pas de décision de finale
d'investissement
vous n'avez pas de
le disons le cadre de financier de
soutien et pas terminé pas parfait
c'est à dire que il y a eu une aide à
tout ce qui est amont donc les IPC c'est
très bien donc le financement de de
gigafactory j'y reviens pas laisser les
10 c'est les 10 projets que j'ai
rapidement esquissé
il est question d'un mécanisme de
soutien à la production d'hydrogène donc
pour combler la différence entre je
dirais de l'hydrogène vertueux et de
l'hydrogène gris on va dire on va dire
ça comme ça mais ce
mécanisme a été notifié à Bruxelles mais
il y a pas de retour à ce jour
vous avez on vous parle d'une banque de
l'hydrogène à Bruxelles
première enfin les prémices enfin
l'annonce a été faite la semaine
dernière le
premier appel d'offres vont être lancés
à l'automne et pour
par rapport à d'autres pays on
investissement il y a pas de complexe à
faire
je crois puisque au moins 9000 en fait
le lors du lancement le gouvernement a
dit on met 7 milliards ensuite le
président Macron lorsqu'il a lancé en
octobre 2021 France 2030 il a rajouté un
mi-9 à ça s'ajoute le Corum le coracle
l'aviation civile le Coran pour la
mobilité
également
dans le c'est également d'enfance russe
donc on est déjà à peu près à 10
milliards donc non il y a pas de il y a
pas de je dirais ce qu'on peut regretter
néanmoins c'est que on a on favorise
beaucoup l'amont et pas suffisamment
Laval et notamment les utilisations et
les usages et je reviens au véhicule
utilitaires légers un véhicule
utilitaire léger de stéréotype au moins
de 100.000 euros donc beaucoup plus cher
qu'un véhicule thermique et l'écart le
reste malgré les bonus le reste à charge
et donc ça va être une difficulté pour
pour décoller
encore un point mais alors là je
pardonnais si je dis une bourde
en
molécule de carburant de synthèse il y a
l'isobutène ça à revoir avec vous ou non
non c'est complètement différent que les
principes ok d'accord je connais pas je
ne sais pas non
on va féliciter déjà René Paul Savary
parce qu'il a réussi à coller monsieur
le Président
et
ingénieur des mines
donc il est médecin et sénateur ça
rejoint peut-être une question que je
suis d'un département où il y a un pôle
de compétitivité autour de la
bio-économie donc on s'est transformé
les notamment les betteraves ou de blé
c'est comme ça qu'on a fait des premiers
fermenteurs etc et donc comme président
de département j'ai je ne suis pas mal
investi à l'époque de dans ce domaine là
donc c'est pour ça que j'écoute toujours
mais avec plus de distance maintenant je
suis beaucoup plus prudent mais propos
e
de compétitivité enfin qui a été monté
là-bas recherche le nom
pour revenir à la société de
Vitry-le-François lafner et le procédé
inoka donc c'est un procédé de
thermolyse ils n'ont pas utilisé
pyrogazification puisque la première
phase est une température plutôt
inférieure celle de la pyrogasie
habituelle et
donc ça ça produit de l'hydrogène mais
on peut ensuite évoluer vers des
carburants de synthèse et ça utilise de
la biomasse
l'ignocellulosique qui qui
a pas de conflit d'usage par rapport à
d'autres procédés
oui peut-être pour rebondir sur sur
cette question sur le type de molécule
de synthèse que l'on vise et qui rejoint
une question de monsieur le rapporteur
sur les usages de l'hydrogène dans la
mobilité direct ou indirecte et les
questions légitimes
d'efficacité juste la première chose et
monsieur le président l'a déjà dit c'est
que Franz hydrogène n'a pas une vision
hégémonique de l'hydrogène ou de ses
dérivée sur la mobilité loin de là bon
les questions sur la sobriété sont
légitimes et ce n'est pas à nous de les
de les traiter une fois qu'on a atterri
sur une demande énergétique dans les
différents types de transport il faut
tout décarboner notre but c'est
d'atteindre la neutralité des carbone à
partir de là sur les carburants de
synthèse que l'on vise c'est par rapport
au type d'usage c'est à dire où est-ce
que des molécules ou des vecteurs plus
efficaces ne pourront pas faire le
travail en l'espèce sur la mobilité
routière le couple batterie hydrogène
utilisé directement que soit en pieds en
combustible ou à combustion directe pour
pour des poids lourds
[Musique]
et le maritime pour la molécule de
synthèse et peut-être pour pour
compléter juste sur ce la question de
monsieur le rapporteur par rapport
voilà au débat sur comment décarboner
notamment le parcoursier et les
questions qui sont soulevées sur
l'hydrogène monsieur le Président a
donné nos hypothèses elles ne sont pas
hégémoniques que ce soit pour le Vel ou
les poids lourds c'est regarder par
usage ou est-ce que la batterie ne
pourra pas faire le travail
juste un chiffre sur 2040 nos
projections ce sont pour les poids
lourds transports au pied de
marchandises c'est 15% du parc mais
c'est 15% on estime qu'ils sont vraiment
sans regret sans l'hydrogène enfin la
batterie ne pourra pas venir les
décarboner et pour mettre un peu en
perspective les les hypothèses qui ont
été données toujours sur le transport au
quai de marchandises on estime environ
Franz hydrogène le déploiement de 85 00
camions d'ici 2030
donc c'est la filière qui dit ça des
études indépendantes je pense notamment
à celle d'équilibre des énergies qui
avait été remise en octobre 2021 ont des
scénarios plus ambitieux que les nôtres
donc les propres hypothèses de la de la
filière transmise sont assez
conservatrices et on vise vraiment le
sang au gré
de 8500 camions d'ici 2030 ça veut dire
que c'est 8500 kg qui pourraient être
construit ou qui pourrait être alimenté
les deux les deux mais déployer et
roulant roulant en France sur les
différents faibles comment ça me paraît
faible parce qu'en plus je peux avoir
des véhicules qui viennent de
l'extérieur c'est 1,4 % du parc
des projections qui sont en effet par
rapport à d'autres études assez comme
l'étude d'équilibre des énergies assez
conservatrices mais qui aboutissent sur
un parc de Philippe la cité un peu plus
de 90 000 poids lourds en 2040 donc il y
a une trajectoire effectivement il y a
un amorçage qui est effectivement un peu
lent mais qui va se déployer comme le
dit Simon la vocation c'est plutôt la
complémentarité d'usage par rapport à
d'autres solutions encore une fois c'est
pas une solution hégémonique néanmoins
il y a un certain nombre de d'usages
pour lesquels il y a pas d'autres
solutions valables moi je reviens un
tout petit peu si vous avez une minute
sur la notion de coût qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure et en particulier sur le
coup du véhicule utilitaire léger donc
je crois qu'on vous l'a exprimé le les
produits sont sur étagères sont prêts à
être déployés et sont commercialisés
d'ores et déjà on a des dispositifs
financiers qui ne sont pas adaptés dans
le cadre du plan national hydrogène
c'est à dire que on n'arrive pas à
suffisamment sera amorcer les 50
premiers mille véhicules utilitaires
léger avec les dispositifs financiers
existants donc on a besoin d'un
dispositif Haddock pour compenser le
surcoût de CAPEX d'achat du véhicule
néanmoins on sait déjà que en termes de
TCO si le mécanisme tirwherbe se met
bien en place on pourra déjà avoir
isocompétitivité au diesel très
rapidement sur la composante coup du
carburant donc on voit bien quand on
prend le coût total de possession pour
un artisan ou pour les les utilisateurs
intensifs du véhicule hydrogène que on
peut prévoir si on a des dispositifs
adaptés à l'amorçage un une baisse du
CAPEX relativement rapide dès qu'on aura
les 50 premiers mille véhicules
utilitaires légers aidé par la baisse
des coûts rapides des équipements qu'on
a cité avec les réservoirs des piles à
combustibles etc pour lesquels l'État
déjà a juste titre et correctement
investi dans ces giga Factory et la
dimension coût du carburant qui pourra
être rapidement compétitif si on se
mécanisme tire ouverte
se sert bien la filière hydrogène et
puis si vous avez un tout petit instant
moi j'avais peut-être un élément sur le
rapport sur la sécurité c'est jeu
d'aider que vous avez mentionnés puisque
donc on a chez franc hydrogène bien reçu
et lu ce rapport on a également été
auditionné
le ce qu'on en tire comme conclusion
elle est double effectivement au premier
abord à première lecture ça donne pas
forcément une image très flatteuse de la
filière même si les constats sont
relativement justes certains égards
c'est à dire filière qui est en train de
de se déployer
néanmoins sur les recommandations
associées à la sécurité plusieurs
recommandations nous sont directement
destinés et on s'en est saisi
immédiatement c'est à dire qu'on a mis
en place des un groupe de travail sur la
sécurité de l'hydrogène on travaille en
collaboration avec le ministère avec le
Barbie ou pour lequel on recense tous
les événements d'incidentologie des
accidentologie on a mis en place ce
groupe pour partager les bonnes
pratiques et donc faire remonter pour la
base de données à rien les éléments les
événements liés à la filière hydrogène
j'ajoute que on est tous très convaincus
dans la filière hydrogène qu'il est pas
question qu'un événement ou un manque de
vigilance sur la sécurité vient de
mettre en péril le déploiement de la
filière donc je crois que tout le monde
est extrêmement vigilant là-dessus et
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas du tout
négligé ce que dit le rapport au
contraire on s'est saisi de des
recommandations on a mis en place des
journées sécurité deux fois par an et ce
groupe de travail au sein de la filière
peut-être juste pour préciser sur sur
les coûts l'illustrer un peu par des
chiffres clés sur les la baisse des
coûts que Madame Verquin mentionné pour
pour les vel on parle bien de surco
initiaux que soit pour les vel ou les
poids lourds d'ailleurs on a une filière
industrielle en amorçage sur laquelle
des économies d'échelle vont être
réalisées rapidement les vel on estime
enfin la plateforme française de
l'automobile estime que l'on réduit le
surcoût par rapport à un véhicule
équivalent batterie de 55% à partir de
5000 véhicules produits par an par
constructeur et on a nos deux
constructeurs positionnés dessus
on arrive à ISO compétitivité à l'achat
sur le véhicule avec un véhicule
électrique batterie équivalent dès que
le seuil des 30000 véhicules par an par
constructeur est atteint ce qui est
projeter en fait dans les dans les
décisions d'investissement
dimensionnement des lignes de production
que sont en train de réaliser les deux
constructeurs français mais également
mais également les équipements tiers en
amont financés stratégiquement par
l'État dans le cadre de la première
vague d'ypcy et juste sur le volume qui
était mentionné effectivement notamment
pour les camions ça peut être faible
mais ça ça revient ce que vous
mentionnez monsieur le rapporteur tout à
l'heure la priorisation éventuelle de la
location de l'hydrogène à l'industrie
dans un premier temps l'hydrogène pour
la mobilité représentera comparativement
à l'industrie et la production de
carburant de synthèse des volumes
relativement faible ce n'est pas une
vraie une vraie concurrence sur le plan
des volumes mais pour autant
si l'on ne développe pas en amorce pas
la mobilité maintenant nous ferons face
soit un effet falaise industriel dans
quelques années quand on se dira bon
maintenant que l'on a décarboné cette
industrie lourde il faut décarboner la
mobilité pour atteindre la Neutra lité
carbone et toute la mobilité ou alors
comme le mentionnel le monsieur le
Président nous serons nous aurons des
dépendances extérieures et nous nous
devrons nous devrions faire venir des
importer des véhicules alors que nous
étions positionnés stratégiquement
Monsieur Bernard buis sénateur de la
Drôme
j'avais juste une remarque par rapport à
ce qu'on est dire là sur la
massification et l'importance d'avoir
plus de construction et ça va être aussi
lié à l'implantation de station de
recharge pour ça bon je sais pas où ça
en est mais dans la Drôme on a une
entreprise qui s'appelle ma fille qui a
gagné un appel à projet qui va mettre en
place 14 stations en Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes donc ça va ensemble je pense
que tant qu'on n'a pas aussi des
stations les personnes ne s'engageront
pas même si on arrive à un prix
quasiment à l'identique d'ici deux ans
c'est bien le sens de l'étude qu'on a
réalisé l'an dernier pour essayer de
voir où mettre ses stations ou est la
bonne position de ces stations donc sur
les grands axes on a pris en compte
également les aider feux les 40 je crois
que c'est 43 ou 45 agglomérations qui
sont qui vont avoir une zone à faible
mission d'ici 2025 donc c'est ça tout ça
qu'on a pris en compte et on a pris avec
le distinguo à la fois des stations de
recharge pour poids lourds enfin je peux
vous donner le chiffre si je le retrouve
c'est lors de 120 à l'horizon
26 c'est 40 stations les chiffres c'est
2026 on prévoit 210 stations pour les
véhicules utilitaires légers et 40 pour
les poids lourds donc un total de 250 la
l'enquête qu'on avait fait prévoyait 200
25 stations à l'horizon 2025 vous voyez
donc
le coût d'une station c'est de l'ordre
de 1 à 2 millions d'euros donc c'est
beaucoup plus cher qu'une bande de
recharge mais ça va beaucoup plus vite
et ça délivre beaucoup plus d'énergie
donc c'est ça qu'il faut voir et puis à
l'horizon 2030 on en est à 920 stations
totales on est toujours à peu près dans
le ratio on avait sorti dans les études
précédentes à peu près 1000 donc
750 pour les véhicules utilitaires
légers et 170 pour les pour les camions
il y a pas que maxi qui fait des
stations il y en a d'autres
peut-être juste pour compléter et
revenir un petit peu sur sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qui va permettre le
déclenchement c'est la bonne
articulation entre les différents
acteurs qui se qui se mettent en place
c'est pour ça que comme la mentionnée
Philippe on a voulu conduire cette étude
en lien d'ailleurs avec la plateforme de
la filière automobile pour paramétrer le
développement optimal des stations de
recharge donc on a pris des hypothèses
au niveau national auquel on a intégré
notamment les contraintes liées aux
règlements européen sur le déploiement
des infrastructures de recharge pour
carburant alternatif la fier puisqu'on
va être contraint de toute façon ne
serait-ce que pour le transit
international d'avoir un certain nombre
de stations à disposition de l'ordre
peut-être de 180 je crois sur le réseau
voilà mais on a on est en train
maintenant de décliner cette étude de
niveau national au niveau des régions et
ça rejoint la question de l'articulation
parce qu'il y a un enjeu de
planification qui peut être à la maille
en effet des territoires du déploiement
optimal des stations en fonction des
différents usages des besoins du
positionnement des métropoles etc et
donc une fois qu'on va mettre sur
rentable pour le compte de chacune des
régions en France
cet outil qui va permettre de paramétrer
le développement optimal d'espacion des
stations on espère que les acteurs les
élus des territoires vont se saisir de
cette occasion pour essayer de
coordonner les fameuses usages dont on a
besoin typiquement dans les métropoles
on peut parler des bus à hydrogène on
parle des benne à ordures également et
puis d'essayer de coordonner la demande
sur en termes d'achat groupé par exemple
voire même de commandes publiques sur
les vel ou sur les poids lourds ça a été
le cas en Occitanie il y a eu ce projet
corridorage 2 qui a initié déjà un
dispositif de cette nature et dernier
point sur la bonne articulation il y a
effectivement les différents acteurs de
la filière à différents moments les
véhicules le carburant et les stations
et puis il y a les différents niveaux de
financement auxquels on va pouvoir faire
appel et qui vont pouvoir en théorie on
espère du moins bien s'articuler entre
eux et là il faut considérer aussi ce
qui existe au niveau européen voire même
des prêts au niveau de la BEI et de la
même manière on encourage les acteurs
des collectivités à mettre en place des
sociétés de projet ou à s'engager
directement dans le dans les projets de
déploiement c'est ça qui va permettre
véritablement de faire décoller la
filière et surtout de soutenir les la
filière industrielle et les acteurs les
PME PMI sur les territoires qui sont
engagés pour ça
il y a des projets quand même il y a des
réalisations vous avez certainement vu
la station hydrogène de la Porte de
Saint-Cloud qui est en train de d'ouvrir
ses portes
de manière un peu cursive quand même je
voudrais qu'on revienne un peu
cranter les choses autant qu'on peut
d'abord
[Musique]
dans quel domaine il vous semble que
l'hydrogène présente un rendement
énergétique
qui est tel que
il est déterminant et il est utile de le
mettre en oeuvre bon sur la sécurité
vous avez répondu
ce que je voudrais quand même que on
regarde si c'est les différents types
d'hydrogène
la capacité de production
est-ce qu'il y a des difficultés est-ce
qu'il y a des limites vous avez parlé
beaucoup de l'électrolyse bon
qu'est-ce qui vous manque si on doit
développer
l'hydrogène qu'est-ce que vous attendez
des pouvoirs publics de la révision de
la stratégie y a-t-il des sujets de
financement puisque vous avez dit quand
même que on n'avait pas franchi le pas
d'investissement
significatif et j'allais dire durable en
tout cas définitif est-ce que ce sont
des sujets fiscaux ce sont des sujets
d'accompagnement
sur ce plan là
voilà quelques éléments quand même mais
essayons de grandir un peu les
différents sujets parce que nous on a
besoin d'y voir clair on comprend bien
que c'est foisonnant on comprend bien
que c'est une technologie d'avenir qui
est un centre de choses qui sont faites
mais voilà essayer de nous préciser
comme un peu mieux les éléments
stratégiques ce que nous ce qui compte
c'est quoi c'est de voir finalement
comment on décolle
vous n'avez pas beaucoup parlé de
l'industrie quand même sur l'industrie
qu'est-ce qui va bien et qu'est-ce qui
reste à traiter ou qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être
utile comme comme décision au-delà de la
mobilité aussi voilà notre sujet global
c'est de comprendre en quoi cette
filière peut être un élément la
décarbonation à côté des autres et
qu'est-ce qui manque dans ce cas là mais
n'hésitez pas à nous dire quand même les
points y compris techniques qui vont
demain être déterminants
moi je refuse de rentrer dans le débat
rendement par rendement je vous ai dit
l'important c'est voir un certain nombre
de critères le rendement en est un mais
ce n'est pas le seul il y a les
questions de disponibilité de
disponibilité de votre véhicule si je
reviens je vais pas répéter les durées
de recharge mais
les questions de d'autonomie pour la je
parle de la mobilité et on a beaucoup on
a mis le focus sur la mobilité parce
qu'on avait compris que c'était les
biocarburants et tout ce qu'il y avait
la mobilité mais on peut l'entendre
la question du rendement du point de vue
environnemental elle se pose
il faut savoir qu'est-ce qui aura le
meilleur rendement du point de vue
environnemental
vous nous dit c'est pour vous avez un
raisonnement je comprends sur
l'autonomie sur la
que vous nous évoquez les batteries pour
les véhicules utilitaires légers ou même
les mêmes les poids lourds voilà mais
nous à quel moment on perd de l'énergie
par rapport à ce qu'on met au début ça
c'est une question que pose on a reçu
les ONG etc et tout c'est une question
qui est venue assez régulièrement
regarde que le rendement
le Parlement le Parlement n'est pas là
pour écouter une filière dire que tout
va bien donc c'est ça la seule
technologie ou que la questionner nous
sommes ici pour poser des questions pour
en toute objectivité comprendre les
choses poser des débats et après on
verra ensemble tous ensemble comment
voilà mais je suis obligé pardon de vous
piquer un peu parce que cette question
là elle est dans la société elle nous
est posée aussi donc aidez-nous à
formuler la réponse
place qui est de dire il y a des
règlements européens et des règlements
et des règles en France issues de
notamment la loi d'orientation des
mobilités ou les lois climat résilience
qui nous oblige à aller vers le véhicule
zéro émission ou très faible émission
dans ce contexte là on n'a pas 50
solutions il y a le véhicule électrique
batterie hydrogène et puis lisse enfin
moteur à combustion interne qui pourra
être également considéré mais si on
considère les contraintes auxquelles on
fait face réglementairement
régulatoirement et bien il y a pas
beaucoup d'autres solutions que la
batterie l'hydrogène c'est pour ça que
notre raisonnement n'est pas d'esquivé
le rendement c'est de dire à un moment
donné quand on a le choix entre une
batterie et un véhicule et hydrogène et
bien les contraintes d'usage font que la
batterie ne pourra pas répondre aux
besoins d'un certain nombre de d'acteurs
économiques des artisans des flottes de
taxi etc dont le modèle économique ne
permet pas soit de passer ne serait-ce
que une heure à se recharger ou deux ne
permet pas de te transporter trois
tonnes et demi de batterie ne permet pas
de ne pas tourner H24 etc si on pense
à des véhicules typiquement SAMU ou
d'autres enedises enfin voilà il y a des
contraintes d'usage et elles sont
nombreuses qui justifient qu'une partie
du parc sera hydrogène dans le cadre de
la mobilité faible émission
s'agissant des capacités de production
pour un million de tonnes de d'hydrogène
il vous faut 55 terawatters
à l'horizon 2030
nous dit que ça passe c'est disponible
donc c'est de l'électricité renouvelable
ou bas carbone nous également notre
souhait souci volonté pugnacité à faire
en sorte que l'hydrogène fait à partir
de d'électricité nucléaire soit reconnue
pour pouvoir être intégré et c'est pas
pour le la c'est pareil c'est pas pour
l'idéologie nucléaire c'est simplement
pour que parce que s'il n'était pas
reconnu on peut penser la plupart des
financiers des banques et autres vont
vouloir verdir leur portefeuille et donc
ils vont aller financer ce qui est
réputé vert pour l'instant on n'a pas
défini vert mais disons ce qui est
renouvelable enfin disons ce qui est ce
qui est bien
ben oui mais c'est tellement enfin c'est
ambigu
ça a pas plu le sens ça a pas plus enfin
ça va pas le même sens chez allemand
chez les Français enfin bon donc on est
dans l'ambiguïté totale nous on est un
seuil on est en dessous du seuil c'est
bon là c'est pas bon enfin c'est donc
et
ça milite aussi donc ça je reste sur
l'électrolyse mais
j'ai bien dit aussi dans mes réponses ou
dans mon exposé que il fallait également
pousser les feux sur la biomasse et
notamment la biomasse ligneuse qui qui
est disponible il faut simplement la
collecter il faut disons développer
cette filière plutôt c'est filière
biomasse ligneuse
mais pardon sur le seuil vous avez enfin
j'entends votre propos qui est de dire
les couleurs c'est pas ça ça explique
pas tout et c'est pas forcément le bon
critère votre seuil c'est c'est quoi
votre seuil ah bah c'est pas notre seuil
c'est il y a eu deux démarches il y a eu
ce qu'on appelait la taxonomie verte
qui est un seuil de trois kilos de gaz
carbonique par kilo d'hydrogène et puis
un autre à une autre approche qui est un
abattement par rapport à la meilleure
technologie disponible en termes de
vapores et formage 70% et là on est à 38
donc le seuil officiel c'est
disons un hydrogène vertueuse c'est un
hydrogène à moins de 3,38 kg de gaz
carbonique par kilo de rejet pour vous
ça paraît être une bonne norme c'est
bien non c'est bien parfait c'est bien
et ça permet notamment compte tenu du
mix électrique français
un
de l'hydrogène fait avec de
l'électricité du mix électrique français
rentre dans ce cadre là et ça d'ailleurs
été reconnu au niveau de la commission
puisque il y avait des critères
d'additionnalités enfin je peux entendre
les détails si vous le souhaitez les qui
ont la France et la Suède sont dispensés
dans la mesure où leur mix électrique
est décarbonée
alors qu'est-ce qui je poursuis dans vos
questions qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
manque je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
monsieur le sénateur c'est
essentiellement par faire le cadre c'est
à dire à la fois avoir
sur le plan financier savoir où on en
est en terme de soutien
je dis le
porteur de projet c'est pas combien il
va recevoir quand vous êtes américain
vous avez le l'iral l'inflation
de réduction actes vous savez que vous
allez réduire
les quantités de gaz carbonique et c'est
x dollar par tonne de carbone éviter
et puis vous cherchez pas le guichet
c'est un crédit d'impôt en Europe c'est
un peu plus compliqué c'est un peu plus
compliqué déjà on sait pas si c'est s'il
faut de l'hydrogène renouvelable enfin
si c'est l'hydrogène renouvelable ou
l'hydrogène pas carbone qui a reconnu et
puis
les conditions de production votre
hydrogène votre électricité renouvelable
est-ce qu'elle sera réputée faire votre
hydrogène
le jour d'avant le mois d'avant la
semaine d'avant trois mois avant donc ça
c'est des questions un peu byzantines
pour lequel on n'a pas encore les
réponses
donc c'est ça qui manque c'est le cadre
puis je vous dis le cadre français il
manque des décrets des arrêtés
c'est tout ce qui manque alors que
qu'est-ce qu'on attend de l'État d'abord
qu'il se battent à Bruxelles pour
imposer ses vues et ça c'est en bonne
voie avec Madame Agnès qui qui a formé
une coalition avec des pays de d'Europe
de de
l'Est laquelle coalition s'oppose à une
autre coalition emmenée par l'Allemagne
avec l'Autriche le Danemark l'Espagne le
Portugal
l'Irlande
j'ai dû en oublier
Luxembourg l'Autriche aussi
ne veulent pas entendre parler de
l'hydrogène d'origine d'hydrogène faite
de l'électricité nucléaire mais donc ça
c'est mais ça c'est fondamental
alors pour l'industrie j'ai pas insisté
sur l'industrie mais je peux en dire un
mot
je suis désolé mais si vous n'avez pas
d'hydrogène je vois pas comment vous
allez réduire du minerai de fer donc
alors vous allez me dire où il y a des
séries électriques mais aussi électrique
il faut déjà une sorte de mousse de fer
où il faut des de la cire recyclée mais
la à la base c'est bien le projet
gravity à fosse ou les les travaux que
enfin le DRI le die right réduction iron
ça existe ça se fait pour l'instant avec
du gaz naturel donc c'est pas c'est pas
encore bon mais les travaux d'Arcelor
vont vers justement l'utilisation de
l'hydrogène pour cette réduction directe
de du minerai pour avoir une espèce de
mousse de fer qui ensuite va passer au
four électrique pour donner les aciers
donc sur l'acier il y a pas de c'est
sans regret le ciment il y a quand même
ça peut permettre
en recombinant et c'est là on retrouve
la question du gaz carbonique industriel
en recominant ce gaz carbonique qui est
fatal puisque dans une cimenterie vous
avez un tiers qui vient du combustible
et deux tiers qui vient de du ciment
enfin de la masse calcaire que vous
traitez la maçonnique que vous traitez
et donc ça les vitrez jamais même avec
le meilleur combustible vous aurez
toujours cette quantité de CO2 et donc
si on peut en faire quelque chose alors
l'alternative c'est quoi l'alternative
c'est de faire un réseau de collecte de
gaz carbonique au niveau de la France
j'ai dit sur les
56 à décarbonées 56 les plus polluurs il
y a beaucoup plus de cimenterie que ça
en France mais les 56 sur les 50 sites
les plus émetteurs de CO2 de gaz à effet
de serre il y en a 24 qui sont
cimenteries ou four à chaud donc on va
faire un réseau de collecte de CO2 pour
emmener ce CO2 jusqu'à fosse ou à
Dunkerque pour charger sur les bateaux
pour aller l'enfuir en mer du Nord ou en
Adriatique bon donc ça serait quand même
assez malin au moins dans une phase de
transition tant qu'on sait pas faire
autre chose avec le CO2 de pouvoir en
faire du méthanol ce serait autant de
méthanol qu'on ne ferait pas avec du gaz
naturel
produit dans des conditions qu'on
imagine à Trinidad de Tobago ou ailleurs
donc
toujours pas
donc ça c'est pour le excusez-moi
ça c'est pour les
cimenteries
l'ammoniac pour faire l'hydrogène pour
faire l'ammoniaque c'est de l'azote et
de l'hydrogène c'est l'hydrogène il faut
qu'il faut qu'il soit vertueux il faut
qu'il soit fait à partir de
renouvelables ou de bas carbone donc
c'est
si
certains domaines de hachimie l'eau
oxygénée c'est pareil l'oxygénée il vous
faut de l'hydrogène le
chimie cimenterie et puis les engrais
je le rapporte
merci monsieur le Président vous avez
abordé beaucoup de sujets merci
notamment sur le sur la production je
reviens alors
j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'on avait
auditionné et qu'on va on va auditionner
un peu tous les tous les partis entre
guillemets sur chacun des des vecteurs
et des carburants que nous traitons on a
entendu quand même aussi la question des
limites physiques contraignant la
production sur la disponibilité de la
biomasse on a parlé un peu tout à
l'heure de l'électricité du CO2 et il y
a aussi ce raisonnement qu'on entend
alors qu'on partage ou pas comme quoi il
faut aller vers un effort sobriété
et qu'il faudra peut-être prioriser
l'usage de l'hydrogène alors comment
vous réagissez par rapport à ça
je répète les priorités
les domaines sans regret c'est
l'industrie de l'autre tel que je viens
de le rappeler et puis
l'aérien le maritime et la mobilité
lourde camion bus ben à ordure et
véhicule utilitaire léger dans certains
cas d'usage d'accord
on volumes de production est à 15% à
l'arrivée pour le la mobilité si j'ai
bien compris les mobilités
utilitaires légers
globale enfin je voudrais plutôt à
réagir mais même à être critique par
rapport à cette idée là qui nous a été
formulé par notamment des ONG enfin
c'est alors déjà été mis en ligne mais
ils vont l'être dans ce cas là c'est
quand même que voilà il faut vraiment
cantonner l'hydrogène parce que on n'a
pas les disponibilités pour la
production qu'il faut être dans une
logique de sobriété mais sobriété on est
tous d'accord enfin je l'ai pas dit dans
mon propos liminaire parce que ça me
paraît tellement évident de sobriété
efficace d'efficacité ça on est j'espère
qu'on est tous d'accord là dessus mais
donc mais une fois qu'on a dit ça après
quel segment quel vecteur on
vers quel secteur on se porte c'est ce
que j'ai dit OK
il va y avoir un besoin il va y avoir un
besoin en électricité en production
d'électricité en énergie primaire
supplémentaire de toute façon quoi qu'il
arrive enfin si on regarde les scénarios
RTE même si on a une trajectoire
d'efficacité de sobriété il reste
néanmoins un parc en mobilité et des
besoins en production d'énergie telles
que oui en consommation d'énergie telle
que le sujet c'est vraiment la location
des meilleures solutions
à l'existant il va pas disparaître même
si on fait de la sobriété oui
normal que je vous fasse réagir là
dessus pour juste pour pour résumer
l'idée mais je pense que les mêmes ONG
auditionnés partageront de c'est qu'en
fait la décarbonation globale peu
importe que l'on parle du vecteur
hydrogène ou d'un autre il faut être
conscient qu'elle nous met vraiment face
à un mur énergétique et industriel et
face à ce mur on aura besoin de tous les
leviers donc on commence probablement
enfin c'est tout en même temps à la fois
on fait de la sobriété pour le transport
on peut envisager des trajectoires de
report modal sur le transport de
marchandises de voyageurs mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça on atterrit sur une
certaine demande énergétique et cette
demande énergétique il faudra la
décarbonate la décarbonée par les
motorisations les plus efficaces
lorsqu'elles peuvent faire le travail
comme l'électrification directe et
lorsqu'elle ne peuvent pas voir quels
vecteurs peuvent le faire
d'accord j'ai peur pardon je vais
peut-être reformuler différemment
quelque chose que vous êtes déjà abordé
mais il voit clair parfois on entend que
il faut produire de l'hydrogène et pour
lui-même si j'ose dire pardon de dire ça
avec des mots un peu un peu naïf
peut-être et parce que à partir de
danger on fera des carburants
synthétiques durables
cette idée de filière un peu verticale
comment vous réagissez là-dessus enfin
est-ce que ça vous paraît être une idée
qu'il faut creuser ou pas
attendez là encore je comprends pas
parce que de toute façon le carburant
c'est hydrogène
d'hydrogène et de carbone oui donc il
vous faut bien les sources d'hydrogène
et ça on le couvre avec de l'électricité
renouvelable ou le bas carbone
[Musique]
ou de l'hydrogène venant de la biomasse
et puis le carbone on revient à la
question tout à l'heure soit du carbone
biogénique et donc là encore de la
biomasse soit du carbone
réutiliser disons c'est ce qu'on appelle
le CCU là le carbone catcheur et
utilisation donc du carbone qui serait
capté sur des installations
industrielles ça ça a pas vraiment
ça a pas vraiment le soutien puisque je
vous dis à partir de 2040 ça sera plus
possible
je suis pas sûr d'avoir répondu à votre
question
non
pour produire des carburants
synthétiques durables on peut passer par
l'hydrogène on doit passer par
l'hydrogène on doit passer voilà on doit
passer par l'étoile et est-ce que vous
oui on doit mais du coup est-ce que il
faut orienter la production d'hydrogène
vers ça
largement ou pas c'est ce que j'ai dit
aussi c'est que
ça constitue des il y a un besoin
important je vais pas y revenir à la
fois donc les CMA CGM merks
l'aérien en demande le besoin de ça
enfin de et important c'est pas vous que
je vais l'expliquer
mais en même temps vous avez évoqué
l'industrie donc tout ça va faire masse
et donc il y aura cette production enfin
il y aura cette production d'hydrogène
pour pas spécifiquement pour le
enfin il y aura cette production
hydrogène pour la production de
carburant synthétique mais aussi pour
l'industrie
on a déjà un besoin en méthanol on a
déjà des besoins
je redis ce que tu disais Christelle oui
on a déjà besoin d'ailleurs en méthanol
pour l'industrie donc les molécules de
synthèse enfin le méthanol en
l'occurrence à la fois pour le transport
maritime mais également pour remplacer
du méthanol carboné que l'on importe
notamment ou particulièrement de
trinidades et Tobago donc ce sont des
marchés existants et juste pour revenir
sur cette idée sous-jacente plus
générale de quel usage on doit prioriser
et est-ce qu'on doit séquencer dans le
temps par exemple d'abord industrie
lourdes de type sidérurgie et ammoniaque
et ensuite carburant de synthétique et
ensuite mobilité routière
ça ne marche pas dans le sens où dans
tous les cas on aura besoin de ces
différents usages pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone et il y a des
réalités de temps de déploiement
industriel et on doit développer ces
différentes usages simultanément ils
appelleront pas les mêmes volumes dans
les mêmes temporalités mais on doit tout
lancer maintenant si l'on veut
structurer une chaîne de valeur
nationale souveraine qui maîtrisera en
fait la molécule qui produira de la
valeur ajoutée sur les territoires avec
tous les équipements liés à cela et donc
des employés ont parlé de la de la
production si on entre un tout petit peu
dans la technique à grande maille la
France a un avantage compétitif sur les
autres États européens Suède accepter
parce que l'on dispose déjà d'un mix
électrique des carbonés ceux qui nous
permet de faire tourner nos
électrolyseurs avec un facteur de charge
très élevé c'est à dire que plus de 7500
heures par an ça c'est un avantage
majeur mais qui sera temporaire 3-4 ans
par rapport au projet qu'on dit
Greenfield pardonnez-moi pour
l'anglicisme c'est à dire les grandes
centrales d'énergie renouvelables qui
qui naîtront dans des pays comme enfin
la péninsule ibérique qui sont largement
dotées en ressources renouvelables soit
on lance maintenant ces projets avec un
avantage compétitif on en profite pour
structurer notre chaîne de valeur sur
l'ensemble des usages
soit on ne profite pas de cette avance
parce que l'on veut séquencer d'abord
l'industrie lourde ensuite les cartes
synthèse ensuite la mobilité et dans ce
cas là on risque il y a un risque de
dépendance extérieur le moment où on
voudra des carboner c'est ces nouveaux
usages une fois de plus ces usages
n'appelleront pas les mêmes volumes
énergétiques les mêmes masses au même
moment mais il faut amorcer maintenant
et profiter de notre avantage
si je peux me permettre
il y a
il y a eu des effets d'annonce il y a
quelques mois
sur l'hydrogène en disant voilà on a la
solution j'entends politiquement moi je
l'ai entendu en tout cas quand on a eu
la crise quand on montait avec des prix
au dessus de 2 euros à la pompe c'est
dit il faut développer l'hydrogène on va
mettre en place une politique dynamique
formidable etc donc et 7,2 milliards
plus etc on arrive à 9 je sais pas si ça
sera suffisant ce que je vois c'est que
le temps est long alors qu'il devrait
être beaucoup plus court
alors moi j'aimerais savoir de votre
part quel est pour vous le cadre fiscal
idéal je dis bien idéal pour faire en
sorte que le développement de
l'hydrogène chez nous puisse se mettre
en place est-ce que vous avez vous des
propositions à faire vous avez dit tout
à l'heure il faut attendre ce qui va se
passer à Bruxelles ce qui va se passer
dans les autres pays j'ai bien entendu
mais ça suffit pas vous vous êtes
peut-être une idée précise de ce qui
serait idéal pour que l'on puisse
développer demain l'hydrogène de manière
compétitive et de savoir à quel niveau
de production d'hydrogène on peut quel
niveau on peut atteindre pour être
autosuffisant par rapport à la flotte
par rapport à l'industrie par rapport à
tout à toutes les énergies par rapport à
tous les besoins et aviation voiture
léger voiture lourdes avec poids lourds
etc est-ce que vous avez justement vous
avez dû réfléchir à ça à savoir
je peux commencer mais je vais laisser
Philippe poursuivre en fait le la
question c'est pas uniquement de la
fiscalité c'est le dispositifs
je vais te laisser réexpliquer mais en
fait on a un enjeu d'accélération en
effet mais qui sera permis quand le
cadre sera clair pour les investisseurs
y compris les investisseurs privés
c'est-à-dire les banques et les
institutions financières donc on a un
enjeu véritablement de permettre que le
cadre régulateur et réglementaire ça
vaut au niveau européen mais ça veut
aussi au niveau français permettent aux
acteurs qui
deuxièmement il y a des dispositifs
financiers qui doivent peut-être être
complétés ou bien articuler donc on a
par exemple parler beaucoup de ce
mécanisme de soutien la production qui
doit permettre de compenser le surcoût
et de massifier la production
d'hydrogène renouvelable ou ba carbone
et donc de compenser le surcoût de
l'hydrogène qui est aujourd'hui produit
par des par des énergies primaires
fossiles simplement ce mécanisme de
soutien la production on l'a annoncé il
y a trois ans et il est toujours pas
lancé
le gouvernement là non le gouvernement
l'a annoncé dans sa stratégie de
septembre 2020 4 milliards 2 4 milliards
on est dans des discussions au niveau
européen qui avec la DG comp et ses
discussions ne sont pas facilités par le
cadre d'investissement le cadre
financier que met en place la Commission
européenne simultanément qui fait que le
gouvernement français s'interroge de
savoir si le mécanisme de soutien la
production et le bon le bon dispositif
néanmoins c'est sur les notes le
gouvernement français pour essayer de
bâtir ce cadre européen ce qui il vous
convient ce qui est suffisant on l'avait
on l'avait initialement ce mécanisme de
soutien d'introduction nous paraissait
effectivement une disposition
utile qu'on avait effectivement proposé
en 2019 et qui a été mis intégré à la
stratégie nationale hydrogène présentant
en septembre 2020 sur les neuf plus de 9
milliards d'euros de la stratégie
hydrogène française c'est 4,2 milliards
qui sont toujours suspendus dans les
discussions avec la DG comp
il s'agit d'une aide d'État il y a donc
ça il s'agirait quand même d'accélérer
ou en tout cas de permettre que ça se
passe puisque ça c'est donc nous on veut
tous accélérer et on est suspendu un
petit peu à ces dispositions et enfin on
a un point pour compléter le dispositif
de soutien Philippe Lady ça a été quand
même assez bien conçu la stratégie
d'hydrogène française c'est-à-dire de
l'amont à Laval simplement on se rend
compte au fur et à mesure que le
l'amorçage en mobilité et le fait que le
modèle économique de la mobilité
hydrogène puisse voler de ses propres
ailes nécessitent un dispositif à
l'amorçage dédié de pour les 50 premiers
milles véhicules mais même déjà dès les
premiers
10000 15000 on est on est déjà sur des
baisses de coude drastique donc ce
dispositif là on a je pense l'écoute des
services de l'État pour essayer de
proposer un dispositif Haddock parce que
les mécanismes financiers existent
aujourd'hui notamment les appels à
projets écosystème territoriaux de
l'ADEME
d'autres ne répondent pas bien à ce
besoin spécifique donc on est en train
de travailler avec les services de
l'État là-dessus je pense qu'on a une
bonne écoute pour proposer un mécanisme
qui irait bien ça c'est vraiment un
point très un point clé en réalité pour
pour nous voilà après peut-être vous
pouvez compléter avec d'autres
presque tout dit simplement l'hydrogène
c'est de l'électricité qui est fait gaz
donc il y a toute la question de du coût
de l'électricité et de ce qu'on appelle
le Market design l'architecture de
marché vous avez bien entendu les débats
qu'il y a notamment entre Paris Berlin
et Bruxelles sur ce qu'on rénove de
Fontan comble market design ou pas donc
des annonces soient été faites le 14
mars dernier mardi dernier à Bruxelles
encore une fois Bruxelles mais enfin bon
on est en Europe et donc
ça va évoluer mais tant que et donc il
faudrait en particulier favoriser et
enfin c'est le la direction qui semble
être prise favoriser ce qu'ils appellent
les pipiers les Power chaise agreement
c'est à dire
un lien direct entre le fournisseur de
d'électricité et puis le consommateur de
façon à ce qu'il est la visibilité
suffisante nécessaire et suffisante pour
s'engager c'est toujours le même
problème si vous savez pas quel prix
vous allez acheter votre électricité et
comme c'est 75% du prix d'hydrogène vous
allez avoir des problèmes pour décider
donc
c'est tout ça qui manquait quand je
disais le cadre c'est enfin je vais me
répéter c'est institutionnel et
financier et juste pour compléter ce
propos sur le prix de l'électricité qui
est qui est clé pour pour toute la
filière et pour beaucoup d'autres
filières industriels d'ailleurs quelle
qu'elle soit il y a le Market design
mais il y a tout simplement la
disponibilité dans la ressource
électrique des carbonées et là on est
sur quelque chose de clé Philippe Le
mentionné les projets qu'on a recensé
francilogène en 2022 qui doivent être
mis en service avant à horizon 2030 font
en appel électrique de 55 terwatters
dans son bilan prévisionnel 2021 2030
RTE considère qu'il y a la marge de
manœuvre tout en prenant en compte les
besoins d'électrification directe
nombreux nombreux par ailleurs marge
manœuvre oui mais la clé pour garder un
système électrique compétitif et des
carboné c'est de les avoir de les
conserver à long terme ces marges de
manœuvre et dans ce cadre-là le projet
de loi d'accélération des renouvelables
le projet de loi d'accélération du
nucléaire qui a déjà été mentionné et
également la loi de programmation
uraniale de l'énergie qui va bientôt
être mis sur la table du Parlement avec
voilà ces échanges 2028 2030 2033 où il
sera décisif de fixer des objectifs
ambitieux d'énergie renouvelables parce
que d'ici 2033 nous n'aurons pas de
nouveau EBR 2 ou SMS New World qui sont
mises en service on est extrêmement on
travaille même dans la main pour la
reconnaissance du nucléaire à Bruxelles
lié à l'hydrogène avec le cabinet d'AGNE
espagnol
d'ici là les deux sont complémentaires
il faut accélérer très fort sur les
énergies renouvelables à la fois pour la
filière hydrogène mais pour l'industrie
en général et pour tous nos besoins
d'électrification en direct
oui bien c'est surprise
si je saisis un peu les choses pour
vis-à-vis de la commission enfin l'Union
européenne en général
il y a la question que que Madame abordé
du du soutien financier et du régime des
aides d'État qui est un qui est un sujet
qui est encore en cours c'est j'ai bien
compris
il y a la question que monsieur le
Président déjà du cadre global
juridique disons avec notamment la
question la reconnaissance
de l'hydrogène vert qui pour nous est un
hydrogène qui peut être produit à partir
d'électricité nucléaire je vais un peu
vite il y a la question du prix
évidemment
bon ça c'est les trois points peut-être
qu'on peut voir je dis ça parce qu'on
aura des discussions avec la Commission
et le Parlement européen je retiens ces
trois points si j'ai oublié quelque
chose et ensuite monsieur aborde vous
l'avez déjà dit tout à l'heure
effectivement la question de de la
capacité qu'on pourra reposer au pouvoir
public et que on aura regardé ici au
Parlement le moment venu pour
effectivement vérifier que on va se
faire dans dans les objectifs qu'on va
se donner on gardera suffisamment de
capacité de
d'électricité entre guillemets pour
permettre que les objectifs de la
filière soit tenues c'est bien ça c'est
différents points je note qu'est-ce
qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui vous paraît
central vous sinon pour
œuvrer la décarbonation via la filière
que que vous que vous défendez est-ce
qu'il y a des points que vous voulez
nous nous indiquer nous signaler ce qui
voudriez assister à des points de
vigilance ou des
choses pour lesquelles vous aimeriez que
les pouvoirs publics fassent évoluer
leur position
c'est plutôt un point de vigilance dans
le cadre de la révision de la stratégie
nationale hydrogène française Philippe
l'a déjà mentionné mais on ne le
répétera pas assez c'est à dire qu'il y
a eu un signal très fort qui a été lancé
beaucoup d'investissements de la part de
la France on a une avance y compris en
termes d'excellence dans la recherche et
dans les technologies de rupture on a un
écosystème qui est très ancré dans les
territoires avec un grand tissu de PME
PMI ce serait vraiment
dommageable de ne pas pousser l'effort
qui est très nécessaire puisque la
compétition elle est mondiale beaucoup
de régions du monde beaucoup de pays
dans le monde se sont mis sur
l'hydrogène pourquoi parce que tout le
monde constate que
d'hydrogène c'est pas la solution
miracle en rien dans aucun segment mais
sans l'hydrogène on pourra pas réussir
les objectifs de décarbonation dans les
secteurs qu'on a déjà mentionnés donc il
faut vraiment pousser l'effort un peu
plus loin et ne pas circonscrire le le
l'usage de l'hydrogène à la
décarbonation de quelques grands sites
industriels parce que c'est mettre en
péril toute la chaîne de valeur
industrielle française qui est en train
de se d'être en place de se mobiliser on
a beaucoup d'exemples on pourra vous en
redonner mais voilà c'est peut-être le
point de vigilance c'est de pas relâcher
l'effort les formes les forts
principales a été fourni et si on lâche
maintenant au motif que 9 milliards
d'euros ont été mis sur la table et que
somme toute ça prend un peu de temps et
bien on risque de d'avoir investi en
vain
aujourd'hui vous êtes en mesure de nous
dire que
produire de l'hydrogène en France par
rapport à nos besoins on peut être
complètement autonome
on dépend de personne d'autre
oui on dépend pas de l'Asie on dépend
pas de la Russie on rajoute une question
à part dans la je me grève dans la
question du président un point que j'ai
regardé pour la fin qui est qu'est-ce
que vous pensez du coup de la stratégie
de l'Allemagne plutôt compris de
l'Allemagne était en une stratégie entre
guillemets d'importation vous prenez des
choses rapidement est-ce que voilà
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
nous dire par rapport à cette stratégie
là qui est différente de la nôtre
l'Allemagne a tout de suite vu que en
termes de développement des
renouvelables donc ils se sont privés du
nucléaire c'est une erreur mais tant pis
pour eux le donc ils ont tellement ils
ont vu tout de suite qu'en termes de
développement du renouvelable ils
iraient pas assez vite et donc il y a le
recours à l'importation
ouais c'est ça donc de recours à
l'importation
et je dirais l'importation sous deux
formes et c'est pas encore très très
nette c'est-à-dire que ils ont pas
complètement exclu d'importer de
l'hydrogène qui serait fait à partir
d'hydrocarbures et
ou disons le à l'issue du vaporé format
on capterait le CO2 et on leur ferait
dans des couches profondes emmerdes du
Nord j'en veux pour preuve le l'accord
qui est signé entre Herve et équinor et
plus généralement entre l'Allemagne et
la Norvège qui va qui parle d'un
hydrogénoduc entre la Norvège et
l'Allemagne alors je sais pas très bien
où va être fait l'hydrogène mais en tout
cas le principe il est là probablement
l'hydrogène sera fait en Norvège mais
pas en Allemagne
bon
en France et
avec disons les efforts qui sont faits
dans le dans le maintien du potentiel
nucléaire voire même dans sa relance
avec les les six opère voir 8
ultérieurement et à plus court terme vu
ce que nous dit RTE à 2030 il y a ce
potentiel de production il faut 55
terravateurs je le répète pour faire un
million de tonnes il y a ce potentiel
RTE nous dit que ce potentiel est
disponible donc il y avait pas lieu il y
avait pas lieu de de
d'imaginer un recours à l'implantation
est-ce que il y aura jamais
l'importation ça disons l'avenir nous le
dira donc parce que c'était une de vos
questions également donc
il y a en particulier il y a eu
l'épisode h2mède enfin nouveau nom de
Barma donc cette liaison entre Barcelone
et Marseille
ça vocation à être un des maillons de la
dorsale
européenne de l'hydrogène mais si vous
n'avez que ce maillon là vous faites pas
le parcours donc ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir en amont développer la
production d'hydrogène renouvelable en
Espagne au Portugal peut-être au Maroc
en Mauritanie
développer les gazoducs qui vont bien
pour l'amener jusqu'à Barcelone de là
avec ce maillon la barbare on va arriver
à Marseille et de Marseille il va
falloir également développer le réseau
pour remonter cette hydrogène vers Paris
Düsseldorf et que sais-je enfin l'Europe
du Nord donc
à quel moment c'est un point que j'ai
pas suffisamment souligné jusqu'à
présent mais bien prendre compte des
temporalités
annoncé pour 2030
personnellement j'ai des gros doutes que
ça se passe en 2030 sera probablement ça
se fera sûrement un jour mais 2030 me
paraît un peu prématuré dans la mesure
où
les premiers projets grands projets je
pense notamment au projet heidil en
Espagne qui vise à développer 9
gigawatts de
photovoltaïques en Espagne en Castille
envoyait faire de l'hydrogène l'envoyer
pour décarboner Arcelor en Espagne ou
vert tibéria qui est la production de de
d'engrais en Espagne c'est que première
étape le mix électrique espagnol et
carboné donc il va falloir le décarboner
l'Espagne va se rendre compte aussi que
avoir de l'hydrogène bas carbone pas
cher c'est aussi un avantage compétitif
donc pas forcément être tenté de
d'exporter donc avant de remplir un
tuyau qui peut transporter 2 millions de
tonnes par an il va se passer à mon avis
quelques années
donc voilà ce que je peux dire sur
l'importation et sur ce
[Musique]
peut-être juste un dernier point de
vigilance
à mentionner on en dira certainement
plus de choses après le 28 mars
puisqu'on organise une journée technique
sur le sujet de 28 mars il y a un enjeu
qu'il faut d'ores et déjà prendre en
compte et que la France doit avoir bien
à l'esprit c'est l'approvisionnement en
matière première en matériaux critique
donc la filière hydrogène est
relativement par rapport à d'autres
filières bien moins concernées il y a
également peut-être des technologies de
rupture pour se placer pour se passer
dans certains noms de de matières
premières critique comme des platinoïdes
mais on n'y est pas encore on va avoir
besoin d'un certain nombre de matériaux
critiques on sait d'ores et déjà vu la
demande d'hydrogène qui est
d'équipements associés évidemment de
production d'hydrogène partout dans le
monde qui va y avoir plus de demandes
que d'offres dans ces matières premières
dans certaines de ces matières premières
donc organiser les schémas
d'approvisionnement je pense à ça à
l'instant parce que quand on parle
d'importation
on considère souvent l'enjeu de la
souveraineté énergétique comme la
diversification des approvisionnements
non pas comme le fait de produire
soi-même nous on considère que et eu
égard à la temporalité évoquée qu'on a
tout intérêt de produire d'ores et déjà
nous-mêmes avec davantage compétitifs de
notre mix énergétique des carbonée qui a
évoqué Simon tout à l'heure mais même si
on pense diversification dans les
matériaux critiques on voit bien que la
production d'extraction de ces matériaux
elle est quand même assez concentrée
dans un certain nombre de pays donc j'ai
pas commencé à parler géopolitique tout
de suite néanmoins voilà c'est un sujet
que la France doit avoir à l'esprit pour
la filière hydrogène mais pas uniquement
évidemment
merci d'avoir merci d'avoir dit
clairement ce que vous pensez sur ce
qu'on appelait Barma voilà parce que
j'allais vous poser la question j'ai
juste une
une d'accord
j'ai juste une dernière question sur
l'aérien vous l'avez abordé tout à
l'heure
technologiquement alors on recevra
les constructeurs et compagnies on a
déjà auditionné l'Académie de l'Air et
de l'Espace et puis le directeur général
de la version civile
le gouvernement avait fait des annonces
qui étaient 2035 avions des carbonées
enfin à faire hydrogène des carbonée
on a plutôt le sentiment depuis
12-15 mois que
on met un peu les zéro freins et on
entend beaucoup plus parler de carburant
synthétique durable pour pouvoir une
forme faire des safs en fait comment
vous voyez ce ce point de maturité de la
technologie sur l'hydrogène pour pour
l'avion
enfin dans l'état où on est on n'a pas
les moyens de faire des on fera pas
mieux que l'Académie de de l'Air et de
l'Espace moi je m'en tiens à ce que dit
Guillaume Faury il dit dans un premier
temps des carburants de synthèse
miscibles au kérosène actuelle dans un
deuxième temps des carburants qui sont
moins miscibles et donc là ça va poser
déjà le problème des chaînes
d'approvisionnement et je l'ai entendu
dire après 2050 l'avion hydrogène mais
c'est Guillaume Faury c'est pas moi
peut-être sur les sur les ordres de
grandeur faire on sait pas encore au
niveau développement de l'innovation
quand est-ce que quand l'avion hydrogène
sera prêt il y a différentes discours
qui sont tenus juste le
ce que ce qui est calculé à peu près sur
la portée qui a été mentionnée tout à
l'heure moyen-courrier par par Philippe
il est estimé par le Conseil
international sur le transport propre
que le l'avion hydrogène pourrait aller
jusqu'à des rayons de 3400 km
transportant 165 passagers donc c'est
c'est si cela est réussi par par les
constructeurs c'est une part non
négligeable mais voilà derrière le il
est certain que les carburants de
synthèse
icérosène ou biocarburant avancé dans
dope le rendement par l'ajout
d'hydrogène seront indispensables et il
y a un rapport et sorti récemment qui
est assez éclairante de l'Académie des
technologies qui donnent quelques ordres
de grandeur une fois de plus ces heures
de grandeur ils peuvent être ensuite
réajustés selon les hypothèses de
réduction de la demande
qui donnait entre 50 et 50 et 75 terres
électriques nécessaires pour la
production de carburant aérien de
synthèse en France d'ici 2040 cet écart
de 50% on fait entre 75 terwatts c'est
selon la disponibilité le niveau de
disponibilité de biomasse durable et
d'ici 2050 ça serait 170 terawatters
électriques qui couvriraient 60% du
secteur aérien français donc ce sera
quelque chose de massif d'où l'intérêt
la nécessité de structurer dès
maintenant une chaîne une chaîne de
valeur et enfin il y a une feuille de
route des carbonation sectorielle de
l'aérien qui a été remise au
gouvernement dans les conclusions ne
sont pas encore rendues publiques mais
ça ça ne devrait pas tarder normalement
sur voilà différence scénarios à la fois
pour l'aérien domestique et
international de décarbonation
vous n'avez pas évoqué le rail
il y a pas d'intérêt
on sait d'où il part on sait où il
arrive
il y a déjà actuellement donc
d'abord là aussi on a un champion qui
s'appelle alsom la le train hydrogène il
roule depuis 2018 en Allemagne il a été
certes construit à saviter en Allemagne
mais la chaîne de traction elle était
faite dans les ateliers à Tarbes en
France
il y a quatre régions qui sont se sont
engagées à acheter des rames
c'est Grand Est
Bourgogne-Franche-Comté Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes et Occitanie
faut voir que le réseau français est
très
très électrifié donc
enfin il est électrifié à boitier mais
c'est 80% du trafic donc la partie qui
est pas électrifiée très faible donc il
y a des opportunités là mais c'est
pareil ça va pas être une généralisation
et ce qui a été retenu c'est un mode
bimode région lisse mi mode c'est à dire
qui pourra à la fois rouler
sous catenaire lorsqu'il y a des
caténaires et puis se passer des
caténaires lorsque
marcher sur la pile à combustible
lorsqu'il y a pas de caténaire
on en est là le
parallèlement Alstom continue à
travailler sur les locomotives de
manœuvre et sur les
sommes mais pas seulement Alstom
également HDF énergie donc qui sont
basés à Bordeaux travailler également
alors là c'est un concept enfin c'est
sur les tout ce qui est motifs de
manœuvre donc avec des piles de
puissance beaucoup plus puissantes que
le train région lisse qui demande des
puissances relativement faibles de
quelques centaines de quand je dis
quelques centaines ces deux ou trois
cent kilowatts alors que pour les
locomotives de manoeuvre on a besoin de
plusieurs méwatts donc là c'est des
piles plus importants donc à Lyon il
travaille
et également je vous disais HDF énergie
donc il y a également là un potentiel
avec des consommations qui vont être
enfin c'est de l'ordre de 200 kg par
jour et par train donc là ça va
permettre également de massifier donc
la SNCF regarde où développeurs où est
le besoin et puis surtout comment
massifier comment regrouper ces usages
là ses besoins là avec éventuellement
des besoins de de stations le long
d'autoroute pour des poids lourds voire
même à proximité de petits industriels
qui auraient besoin également
d'hydrogène donc c'est cette
massification qui faut organiser c'est
ce planification écologique alors on est
qu'au tout début puisque
j'ai cité les deux études de 2022 d'une
part essayer de recenser les projets et
d'autre part
voir quelle est la structure
l'infrastructure optimale de recharge
sont des briques que nous apportons mais
ensuite il faut comme l'a dit Christelle
au niveau chaque région avoir une étude
ce qu'on a fait c'est un peu je dirais
Top Down c'est à dire mais maintenant il
faut repartir du terrain et au niveau
des délégations de délégation régionale
au niveau des des services des régions
des services
voir comment on peut regrouper et avoir
ces créer ces écosystèmes territoriaux
c'est vraiment le mot écosystème
territoriaux sur lequel j'allais
rebondir parce que quand on pense
locomotive de manoeuvre on pense dans
des zones en particulier industrielles
au Portugal ici et je pensais également
à au travail que vous menez pour
interroger les acteurs et sur l'aérien
vous pouvez également interroger les
acteurs des zones des écosystèmes
aéroportuaires qui voient dans
l'hydrogène un ensemble de d'usages qui
sont à terme l'avion mais avant cela
d'ores et déjà un certain nombre de
véhicules qui sont présents sur ces
zones aéroportuaires donc on voit que
dans les zones industrielles au
portuaires les bases logistiques et les
zones aéroportuaires et ça constitue
autant d'écosystèmes territoriaux qui
rassemble une multitude d'usages pour
lesquelles l'hydrogène
constitue de ma vue de manière globale
c'est à dire production pour l'ensemble
de ces usages mutualisés trouvent
complètement son sens
oui sur ce point on a bien le sujet à
l'esprit je vous rassure mais il y a un
autre point qui est quand même un point
réglementaire et de et de
conciliation des règles qui sont celles
aujourd'hui liées ou kérosène et puis
potentiellement l'hydrogène sur les
aéroports c'est pas c'est pas un sujet
qui encore bien bien documenté ça
commence à l'être voilà mais bon la
partie des points en tout cas merci de
l'avoir signalé voilà pour ce qui me
concerne en tout cas je vous remercier
on vous a posé énormément de questions
de de manière très interactive et
directe et je crois qu'on a appris
beaucoup beaucoup de choses merci
effectivement j'ai peut-être encore une
dernière question purement technique
mais moi je cherche à faire en sorte que
demain on puisse être moins indépendant
du reste du monde et moins vulnérables
en matière d'approvisionnement
énergétique et je me dis que quand je
prends ma voiture et c'est une réflexion
que me faisait Jean-Martin Foltz il y a
quelques années quand il était président
de PSA et il me disait tu vois une
voiture qui va faire 100 km elle va
consommer 6 à 7 litres de carburant
fossile avec un moteur thermique et bien
si on embarquait dans la voiture une
pile à combustible qui elle permettrait
de satisfaire les besoins électriques et
or déplacement on pourrait économiser 3
à 4 litres de consommation du véhicule
au 100 km à l'époque enfin ou peut-être
deux lits ou peut-être enfin bon mais
une vraie diminution est-ce qu'on peut
envisager ça parce que dans le fond ça
permettrait de planifier plus largement
sur tous les véhicules et de faire une
décarbonation peut-être plus plus
répandu plus vaste et plus efficace
est-ce que c'est quelque chose
d'envisageable d'avoir ce mixte
énergétique avec l'hydrogène
et question que je vous renvoie pourquoi
il parlait pas de batterie à ce
moment-là
mais vous embarquez effectivement vous
embarquez quand même un
faites pas l'hydrogène de façon exogène
par l'électricité mais vous le utilisez
un carburant
mais vous avez sûrement encore
ça doit forcément rejeter du carbone
enfin vous avez sûrement une économie
mais vous rejetez forcément du carbone
[Musique]
je vais poser votre question
messieurs nos collaborateurs vous voulez
poser des questions
oui ben écoutez nous allons monsieur le
Président Madame Monsieur vous remercier
de votre disponibilité et puis de
s'échange de cet échange qui s'est fait
tout à fait simplement en tout cas notre
niveau oui
je vous remercie également pour la
qualité des questions et les chambres si
je peux permettre quelques mots en
conclusion c'est premièrement
l'hydrogène ne fera pas tout mais on est
convaincu vous allez me dire de la part
de des représentants de la filière
hydrogène vous allez pas attendre moins
mais sans hydrogène réussira pas la
transition écologique et donc c'est pas
en mettre partout c'est la plupart des
modèles donnent 15% de la consommation
finale d'énergie 15% entre 10 et 20%, ça
va dépendre des pays 15%. il y aura
entre 50 et 60% d'électricité 15%
hydrogène et le reste avec de la chaleur
renouvelable et avec de les avec des gaz
renouvelables comme le biométhane
deuxièmement je crois qu'il faut se
garder de tout dogmatisme et regardez
les cas d'usages j'insiste là dessus les
cas d'usage il y a une complémentarité
des solutions c'est à dire la batterie
est complémentaire d'hydrogène et
vice-versa donc complément
regardez les temporalités je citais
alors le cas de RTE ou de NS10 et les
durées raccordement les durées pour
faire les projets ça n'arrive pas comme
ça enfin il y a donc bien regarder les
temporalités l'hydrogène c'est
maintenant donc les autres pays avancent
il y a 50 pays dans le monde qui ont une
stratégie d'hydrogène ou une feuille de
route et il y en a 40 autres qui sont en
train de préparer leurs feuilles de
route et leur stratégie donc peut-être
qu'on se trompe mais on est vraiment pas
les seuls à se tromper donc
il faut vraiment y aller les autres
avancent
l'intérêt je reviens sur le débat
mobilité industrie l'intérêt de la
mobilité ce sont des projets de taille
plus modeste que qui peuvent être
développés maintenant l'industrie ça va
être des gros projets donc ça va
demander plus de temps toujours la
question des temporalités donc là on
peut démarrer tout de suite et ça
donnera également des vitrines également
à nos à nos champions là stay antis et
Renaud pour éventuellement exporter
parce que pour donc c'est aussi une
contribution au commerce extérieur donc
et
c'est possible le maintenant et les
feuilles de route que ce soit celle de
l'aérien que vous connaissez ou du
maritime ils ont absolument l'hydrogène
ou des carburants de synthèse dans leur
feuille de route en plus de la sobriété
je vais indiquer ça dans la conclusion
pour que ce soit bien bien dit on est
évidemment pour la sobriété évidemment
et
enfin je dirais
si on ne fait que l'industrie bien
évalué les conséquences de ne pas faire
dans la mobilité et je reviens à mon
point précédent c'est-à-dire
de possibilités d'export qu'on n'aura
pas des possibilités de développement de
nos champions qu'on n'aura pas et j'irai
jusqu'à dire à quoi bon avoir financé
des gigafactory de réservoir de pile à
combustible si on va pas jusqu'au bout
c'était même pas la peine de financer
ces champions
je vous remercie merci à vous et bon
retour merci beaucoup merci